wait and if you've heard of a ping
before okay yeah all right I'll people
we've got the hands-on in what context
do you hear the word pink okay internet
gaming command line I heard so excited
okay okay all right well our way Ricky
can you say that again slowly and
clearly say it again okay all right I
think you actually said something a
little more colloquial than that but
I'll doing what you said so what's going
on so he's a phrase for you okay let's
just unpack what it means and I think
you can see what it has to do with
communications systems right and then
we'll get a bit more of a formal
definition of what this is ok so here
hmm i suppose this is being used as a
noun right okay so ping as a noun what
does it mean it refers to a time so this
999 I'm usually its measured as
milliseconds okay usually okay and the
larger the time is if the slower a
system or a player or a terminal or a
nerd is ok so as a noun it's a period of
time we measure in your second sir 999
would be I guess that's like one second
right okay now that's the sort of
colloquial use of the word right and if
you're on the same network or someone
you'll have a really really small pig
and people like well I really little
pink today that's a really good thing
okay um sometimes really he gets
European but usually like pretty good is
sort of in the a two digit pin is pretty
good okay now when is it actually come
from well or what does it actually mean
then now it comes from above right
peeing actually means it's a process
that you do right namely it's calling
for a response
okay it's it's going to someone and
saying hey are you there can you talk to
me okay now i'm going to give this a go
I'm not logged in as the administrator
so there's every chance that it's not
going to work for me but I'll give it a
go okay let's try it shall we okay yeah
bingo all right I know well yes and no
it's sort of explanation that hungry
yeah yeah yeah that's true okay all
right so what are we looking at number
one this of this black and white sort of
dark arts sort of thing is called a
command prompt okay but that's the point
but what it lets me do is that lets me
input commands to the computer hence
command prompt and I entered them in
text believe you're not once at a time
or computer games looked like this I
play this game called Zork 0 RK and the
whole game was like this and you you had
options like go to the left or go east
and like pick up a flask and you know
find a map in any way was very
entertaining for my generation that was
interesting ok now it's putting around
my display settings that stranger now
whatever what did i do here have a look
at this some phrase here ok so ping is
is the command that I put it right it's
a verb right that's why it's about
calling for a response so what I can do
after ping actually i'll give you i'll
show you really quickly so this this
command this program has all these
different options for things that i can
go to things that i can specify there's
a long list anyway i'll come back up to
what I actually do I want to go to this
address right and ask for a response
from them ok so you can see what's
happening here it says I'm pinging this
website w calm with 32 bytes of data so
I'm sending something along that's
asking for a response ok now you might
also notice that I've got these numbers
in here with us their IP addresses right
so all the computers and serves on the
internet they speak in terms of numbers
right much like you would say rather
than saying a Clavius house you would
say you know 17 231 felton road Carly
okay and even though that might seem
very strange to someone who's outside
from the country that actually means
things to me and I assume it doesn't
live in school by the way if you're
following anyway then what happens now
in between here unfortunately i would
have liked it that this would have
worked but it's probably cuz of the
proxy it says there's a reply from and
then there's another computer ok now can
almost certainly guarantee that this
computer here is the proxy server
sitting up in the library ok and it's
giving us a response so my ping might
message my call for a response went
through a few steps and got to here and
it said that sorry not letting yeah i'm
not committing to remember the firewall
we looked at that video ok it's not
letting me get out and get a response ok
so that's why it says destination net
unreachable ok so therefore what happens
here ping statistics packets which you
remember they're just little bits of
data right i said four of them i receive
for back none of them were lost they
didn't disappear but they were returned
to me by someone who I wasn't actually
wanting it from so you can go home ok
I'll open up the command prompt at home
you may want to drop this down ok under
your Start menu you can't see it on this
one but you look for something called
Ron if you can't see it if you always
look like this just press down your
windows button and our offshore to run
okay oh yeah that'll do I suppose anyway
if you do if you do it this way you look
like more of a arm a more pro right so
this is what's called the run dialog
going to let you run any kind of program
that's on your computer and i put in CMD
which is short for command okay when you
do that this will come up and you can PM
google and see what happens what will
happen is in here it'll respond and i'll
say look here's your packet back okay
sorry you can you ping any website ya
know okay i'm special okay um so it will
actually return the packet to you and
will give you here's the crucial thing
it'll give you this now right it'll give
you the time in milliseconds it might
say 34 milliseconds or 102 or whatever
number however long it took to get that
response ok so tell you right here
describes once what is meant by
appearing it's two things it's a noun
it's
it's the time okay and it's the verb
which is the actual act of trying to get
a response and see how long that takes
okay